[Applause]
foreign
happy glorious Monday everybody what a
gorgeous audience
I don't say that to just any audience
meet me later
so President Biden arrived in Ukraine
early Monday morning not only were the
ukrainians surprised but so was Joe
he was told by his handlers he was
headed to Disney World
it was a surprise visit a one-year
anniversary of Russia's Invasion there
he announced an additional half billion
in U.S assistance
you know I'm thinking uh it would have
been great if Russia attacked East
Palestine
ouch isn't a
get the money and they would the
president would visit moving on
but this dominates headlines today as it
should considering that's our tax
dollars right and it's all about Unity
that Joe wants to show everyone we're
unified in the fight against Russia but
what about Unity here it's one thing Joe
boasted would be his specialty but every
time he claims to heal he just gleefully
salts the wound like it's a terrified
slug
late last week he hosted a screening of
the movie till about the 1955 lynching a
15 year old Emmett Till in Mississippi
now obviously that crime was horrifying
and it's important story to tell but
here's the odd part during that speech
Biden also said this
you know folks lynching is pure Terror
Lynch for simply being black nothing
more
with white crowds white families who
gathered to celebrate the spectacle
taking pictures of the bodies and
mailing them my postcards hard to
believe but that's what was done and
some people still want to do that
I guess so but I think it's the
politicians not to black people
when they say like that
some uniter so he's saying that white
people gathered to celebrate taking
pictures of bodies and some people still
want to do that now so in his mind or
what's left of it lynching is alive and
well well way to turn down the
temperature with gasoline and a blow
torture unifier I gotta calm down
deep breath it's President's Day so what
evidence does he offer to support this
uh claim I mean even Jesse smallett
brought a sandwich
[Laughter]
Joe offers nothing and his words white
crowds are still perpetuating violence
against blacks but moments later he
points to the death of Tyree Nichols
so many black and brown family parents
have to have that similar conversation
with their children
worrying about whether they'll come home
from a walk down the street or plane in
the park
or just driving a car like we saw Tyree
Nichols this last month
now we know Nichols wasn't the victim of
a white mob but a five black police
officers the last time I checked they
didn't identify as Caucasian
so if lynching is still alive and well
why not name some of these present day
lynchers is it Mitt Romney remember
Biden already said he would put blacks
back in Chains and given that Joe was
Pals with Robert Byrd a former KKK
member who he eulogized after his death
in 2010. maybe you should have some of
these creeps on speed dial obviously
today Society finds lynching abhorrent
in the guilty or convicted of murder but
the way Biden would have you believe it
not only do white people want to Lynch
blacks it's a widespread problem you
know like climate change or violence
against trans Eskimos with dyslexia
I hear it's really tab
down Biden knows he's lying
but he's reading what's put in front of
him without questioning a word you have
to hand it to the Dems for making him
the nominee they found the only person
mindless enough to say garbage they
themselves wouldn't have the balls to
say if they sat in the Oval Office and
he never seems to realize that saying
like this actually makes things a whole
lot worse yet he claims he in the White
House are working to improve race
relations in this country yeah and I
bought those new binoculars because I'm
a bird watcher
that's what I tell the cops but the
White House is in a weird place you
can't tout progress in race relations
because that means you can't tout fear
of Whiting oppression must be alive and
well or Whitey ain't so bad right Joe
I got involved in the Civil Rights move
as a public defender I thought you could
defeat hate because we passed the Civil
Rights Act so many other things
but I learned a lesson hate never goes
away
it just hides under the Rocks until it's
given a little Oxygen by lousy people
well lucky for Joe no one has ever
accused him of getting too much oxygen
so is Joe the Civil Rights Warrior he
claims he was I mean he lied about being
arrested at civil rights protests he
sponsored a cry bill that put millions
of blacks Behind Bars the most he's done
for civil rights it's get lost at an
airport in South Africa
so that's his message on current race
relations hey it was bad way back when
but get this it's still really bad and
you're welcome seriously if progressives
are about race and it's still a racist
world then it's kind of got to be on
them but maybe it's just all about
projecting fear the fact is the last
couple of years haven't been great for
our country and so all Joe has to sell
is fear and with Joe in Ukraine maybe we
should be pretty scared after all in
Joe's head World War III could eliminate
racism entirely
let's welcome
tonight's guest she's got more sense
than a penny arcade former presidential
candidate and Fox News contributor
Chelsea Cabra
he water boards his lawn former CIA
operative and author of the new book
company rules Mike Baker
like a torn ACL he makes you weak in the
knees former military intelligence
analyst and Fox News contributor Brett
velikovic
foreign
Doctor Drew Pinsky
Tulsi does it bother you by the way
welcome to the show thank you pleasure
to see you good to be here um does it
bother you that Biden sold himself as a
totally different thing that he turned
out to be I actually thought well you
know the worst thing that could happen I
mean I actually think maybe he could be
good for the country by being boring
yeah right and not like like just not
costly it turns out he's more of a
divider than anybody we've had
completely the opposite as you said of
of what he promised the American people
when he ran and you know that was one of
the that was one of the main reasons why
I left the Democratic party is because
of exactly those kinds of comments that
he said uh it represents what so much of
the democratic party leadership was
about which is hey let's Fuel and and
foment those flames of divisiveness
let's tear people apart because we know
that when they are torn apart and they
are angry and they are running around
out of fear then the stronger the party
leaders are and the more money they can
raise and Advance their own political
ambition without any care for the the
long-term detrimental impacts in the
country without any care for what kind
of present we need right now we need
someone who can heal these divides who
can bring us together who can remind us
the foundational principles of who we
are as a country and and where we can go
together you know you're a doctor
obviously you claim to be one but more
importantly more importantly but more
importantly I want to thank you for
inviting me tonight when we have these
three military Representatives here and
thank you for your service they
courageously served our country about my
service you're and for through to all of
us but I was on a reality show we
pretended to be special operatives
was basically a version your way of
plugging your next job it really isn't
it's just I just kind of was odd that
here I felt completely I'm underwhelming
compared to what show is this what are
you gonna be on it's on Fox network so
yeah what's it called special ops
um no I want to ask you about it what
what happened no don't worry no please
don't you started this I got sick
your wife has texted me twice about
dinner
it looked like fun though you're in
trouble you should never have me back
you know what do you think about these
psychological or even physiological
impacts of this sort of thing on
somebody's head the constant dividing
and it's it's horrible literally I feel
it in my gut when I hear it because the
reality is there are people who feel
like this the reality is different but
there are people who feel what he is
putting up flame under yeah and what we
should be talking about is how we got
here our special history and what we got
to do to solve it and not just inflame
it constantly it really it it gets in my
chest and my guts it hurts yeah and they
gotta stop we got to teach Civics again
we got to teach about reconstruction
which is the real violence that led to
this moment interesting is that a theory
or a fact I'd say it's a fact you guys
agree I don't know I'm terrible with
history
oh they're plotting you guys don't know
History either awesome we'll go out all
right Brett what do you want to talk
about you want to talk about this you
want to talk about Ukraine let's talk
about this why not go why not I've been
thinking about it and I'm a dad now
since the last time I saw you so thank
you I had nothing to do with it I'm an
adult I'm an adult you have to listen to
me now yes you have to listen to me yeah
no I was thinking about this topic
earlier and I just think like I'm so
happy Joe Biden is so focused on the
most pressing issues today of society I
mean apparently now we have a lynching
epidemic yes we have to worry about from
decades ago you know forget about the
fentanyl crisis forget about you know
war on the border or Chinese Espionage
all around us to me like the way I see
it is Joe Biden has become the great
divider right he's no longer this
unifier that everyone's been talking
about for for so long and it's just sad
for him to create this racial divide in
our country right now that's not needed
you know what happened we got tricked
into thinking the old guy was benign oh
he'll just get in there what can he do a
patch on the back if he goes play he
goes to play golf we didn't it didn't
dawn on his back that he would be a
vessel except I predicted it but he
would he was a vessel right well I made
some amazing predictions that have come
true trust me but don't trust me on the
market uh but anyway I interrupted no I
think you'd hit the nail on the head
thanks Ray for making my point
I like the cut of this gym I don't even
know what that means Mikey how are you
I'm good man excellent do you have
anything you want you have a kid did you
get a baby yeah she's got another kid
um we're a co-parenting
people uh people don't know that I guess
I just went out with it but uh yeah I
heard the doc's got a show is that right
train with special ops reality show he's
already laughing at me so I think he's
seen me he knows who I am I think with
Biden the thing is you never know what's
going to come out of his mouth right and
so thank God that's not a problem with
you no exactly
pretty pretty much sure we know what's
going to happen here uh but I think uh
thank you uh but I think the uh the the
bar is so low at least I set the
Barcelona look Biden won because he
wasn't Trump right he didn't win because
he's a brilliant orator or he's smart or
he's not a unifier so you have to set
the bar really low and understand that
half that he says is just extemporaneous
talk I this word extemporaneous I I look
like today and I I told my wife you used
it well I know right and so uh that's
all I got to say about that right right
I mean you have to understand talking to
a specific audience he has to he has to
maintain you know a certain kind of tone
and stuff like that but he's when he's
saying that there's a whole group of
people out there that want to kill you
that can't be healthy for anybody no
wonder no matter what the circumstances
is if you're at a movie premiere with a
very serious topic or not you're saying
things like that helps nobody well it
helps it helps the party it helps the
Democratic party because I think I
actually the the oxygen for that party
right now is divisiveness and hate right
and and that and the fear and you
mentioned that right I mean it's but I
think it's absolutely true as a
progressive Tulsi no she tells I'd still
say you're a progressive right what does
that even mean no I think that if if do
you think that divisiveness is there
because they know that if you would come
together as a class of no matter the
color that would be the bigger threat it
would be right it would be yeah
um you know I I think it's very
revealing that they're not speaking to
you know you talked about The Tyree
Nichols case you talk about moms at home
in inner cities who are scared for their
kids who even go to school who are
scared that their kids don't see any
future Beyond joining a gang and work in
the work in the corner right if
President Biden was serious about
actually solving problems those are the
things that he'd be addressing exactly
all right we got to move on oh man all
right here we go oh man hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else